Southwest Airlines started inspecting
engines in its fleet of Boeing 737s the
type of plane involved in this week's
deadly engine explosion the ultrasonic
tests are checking for possible cracks
in the metal fan blades one of those
blades snapped during Tuesday's incident
due to metal fatigue that caused the
engine to break apart Kris Van Cleave is
here with new details about the scary 22
minute ordeal
Kris good morning good morning on
Capitol Hill there are growing calls for
hearings and investigations following
the accident Southwest is now confirming
it's giving passengers on this flight
five thousand dollars and this morning
we are getting a look at the terrifying
moments and heroic actions inside the
damaged 737 also we've noticed a
troubling pattern of passengers
unprepared for what to do during an
emergency in the sky moments after the
737s engine exploded sending shrapnel
through a cabin window passengers rushed
to help the injured and dying he did
amazing Stephanie Needham was on board
Southwest flight 1380 her husband Andrew
a firefighter from Texas knew something
was wrong seven rows behind him I looked
at her eyes and she basically gave me
the approval to go back there felt moved
to act as well as other people on that
plane Tim McGinty it was he was my big
guy had my back fellow Texan Tim McGinty
who was traveling with his wife Kristen
helped meet him pull 43 year old
Jennifer Reardon back inside the plane
she was nearly sucked out that shattered
cabin window the mother of two did not
survive the force of the wind it was
just impossible for him alone to pull
her back in there was nothing we could
do to help were nothing he could do to
save her and we just feel for them
because I know they're grieving
[Music]
after the engine failure pictures show
many passengers incorrectly wearing
their oxygen masks which deployed after
a rapid drop in cabin pressure the masks
are meant to be worn over both your
mouth and nose
we give explicit instructions about what
to do when that mask drops Sara Nelson
president of the association of flight
attendants as many passengers ignore
important preflight safety instructions
including how to use the oxygen masks
we're not just there to serve you a coke
we're actually there and required to be
on the plane because we have certain
safety functions that we have to perform
to keep the passengers in our care safe
Nelson says two-thirds of safety
briefings are now given on video and she
believes that can lead some fliers to
think it's the start of an in-flight
movie so fewer people pay attention but
as they tell you and as is described
here in the safety card there is a way
to put on the mask it needs to go over
your nose and mouth and there's a reason
you want to wear it like this because if
you depressurizing the plane and your
nose is here you're gonna be sucking in
air that you there's not enough oxygen
in that air you're gonna still pass out
in as little as 30 seconds so yeah but I
mean just I'm just looking at you right
now you it doesn't even fit snugly
around there's a whole area in here and
I don't see that it's not there's no
nose cutout to guide you and Chris most
people never read this card no but you
know what take now just take 30 seconds
and look at this before you get on it
before you take off yeah or right now go
watch one of the videos on youtube I
mean in other words if you're too busy
at the beginning of the flight you can
go figure this out beforehand you can
you know in these situations people are
gonna panic so you want to just have it
almost second hand and if it means you
know thirty Seconds to where the exits
are count the number of rows to the exit
and just remember it goes over like this
yeah they're gonna read this or how
about paying attention to the flight
attendant how about that thank you very
much Chris sure thank good to have you
at the table that's very important stuff